herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
wir haben uns entschieden heute in der
Redaktionskonferenz darüber zu sprechen
und dann heute Abend zu senden dass wir
noch mal auf die Ukraine schauen wollen
es gibt nicht die eine Nachricht heute
nicht die eine Schlagzeile es gibt auch
wenn man überhaupt den Krieg davon
sprechen kann keinerlei Erfolgsmeldungen
heute auch wieder auf russischer noch
auf ukrainischer Seite vielmehr ist es
eine Art schmutziger Alltag in einem
Krieg wir werden gleich reden über
Energieversorgung über die Wasser- und
Infrastruktur wir werden uns fragen wie
blutig dieser Krieg noch wird wie
schmutzig und was Nachschub bedeutet in
diesen Zeiten wenn der Winter jetzt
kommt was Verluste bedeutet und welche
Strategien beide Seiten fahren
und es geht darum für beide Seiten Ziele
zu erreichen jetzt noch bevor der Winter
dann da ist und eine Stadt nimmt dabei
eine besondere Rolle an und zwar im
Süden da bahnt sich wirklich eine
Schlacht an möglicherweise ein
Häuserkampf das wird sich entscheiden in
den nächsten Tagen wir sprechen mit
unserem Korrespondenten im Land und mit
dem obersten Allee Wolfgang Richter von
der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
natürlich sind wir auch wie immer
interessiert an euren Meinungen und
Kommentaren die könnt ihr im Chat
stellen oder jetzt in dieser
eingeblendeten Adresse auch natürlich
unter ZDF heute-live@zdf.de
als der Krieg begann wach Herz und
schnell in russischer Hand jetzt beginnt
die Ukraine damit und wir erleben Sie
immer wieder und haben es auch den
letzten Tagen gemeldet es gibt an vielen
Stellen
vormarschmärsche und auch ein
Erfolgsmeldung die es immer wieder gibt
aber speziell dort bei Person stockt
dieser Vormarsch warum ist das
eigentlich so wir machen uns ein Bild
von dieser Stadt von dieser
strategischen Bedeutung die sie hat und
das fast Nika zusammen
die südukrainische Stadt treson ist seit
Beginn des Krieges von Russland besetzt
doch jetzt stehen ukrainische
Streitkräfte 25 km vor der Stadt laut
ukrainischen Angaben rücken die Truppen
täglich 500 Meter vorson ist
landwirtschaftlich und wirtschaftlich
von besonderer Bedeutung es verfügt über
Kraftwerke und stausehen die die Krim
versorgen auch strategisch hat ressen
für beide Parteien eine wichtige
Bedeutung sollte die Ukraine Versand
zurückerobern könnte sie der Krim die
Trinkwasserversorgung abschneiden und es
wäre wohl auch die Basis für die
Rückeroberung der Halbinsel der rason in
der Nähe der niepo-mündung am Schwarzen
Meer liegt könnte eine Rückeroberung
auch die Zusammenarbeit mit der Türkei
in puncto Getreidelieferungen Stärken
für Russlands Truppen würde ein Verlust
von tresson bedeuten dass sie nicht
weiter Richtung Westen vorrücken können
sie könnten der Ukraine außerdem nicht
mehr den Zugang zum Schwarzen Meer von
mikolajew bis Odessa abschneiden
und mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt Oberst ad
Wolfgang Richter ich habe schon gesagt
von der Stiftung Wissenschaft und
Politik kann mich jetzt sehen und hören
ich sehe auch einen schönen guten Abend
schönen guten Abend Herr stephanski der
Think Tank Madison policy Forum mutmaß
treson könne Putins Stalingrad werden
ist das ein zu großer Vergleich oder ist
da was dran
also ich glaube dass der Vergleich ein
bisschen überzogen ist aber natürlich
hat Carson eine besondere Bedeutung
zunächst einmal politisch es ist die
Hauptstadt des Gebietes Carson das ja
jüngst von Russland annektiert worden
ist und insofern ist der Song natürlich
von hoher symbolischer Bedeutung zum
anderen scheint es in dieser Region auch
ein Problem der Kollaboration zu geben
und wie sie schon sagten ist ja sondern
du Kriegsbeginn relativ schnell in
russische Hand gefallen und die Frage
stellt sich natürlich warum hat man
damals am Sniper nicht die Brücken zum
Beispiel gesprengt oder nachhaltiger
verteidigt das ist aber später geschehen
und es haben ukrainische Kräfte sich
dort konstituiert und seit vielen Wochen
bereits taktische Gegenstöße vorgenommen
die dann doch im in der Summe zu
erheblichen gebetsgewinnen geführt haben
jetzt haben sie noch etwa 25 km vor sich
und die ein Statements die sie gemacht
haben teile ich völlig das ist für beide
Seiten von Bedeutung einmal für die
Russen was den weststoß Richtung Odessa
betrifft und die Abriegelung der
schwarzwaldküste und für die Ukraine
umgekehrt natürlich ein erstes
politisches symbolischer Gewinn die
Hauptstadt eines annektierten Gebietes
zum anderen aber auch eine Festung
sozusagen wenn Sie den verteidigt wird
von den Russen so sieht es ja aus die
dann in Richtung Krim den Weg eröffnet
allerdings liegt davor noch der Knieper
also so einfach ist es dann auch nicht
denn die Brücken über den depper oder
nipo in Ukrainisch sind ja von den
Ukrainern beschossen worden und
beschädigt worden und lassen nicht mehr
viel Logistik über diese Fluss kommen
vielleicht wenn ich kurz mal dazwischen
gehen kann gerade was Nachschub
anbetrifft ist ja ein wesentlicher Punkt
für beide Seiten wo sehen sie da die
größten Gefahren momentan und
Schwierigkeiten
also für die russische Seite ist das
natürlich sehr schwierig Person mit
Logistik zu versorgen also Munition und
Ersatzteilen aber auch den Verwundeten
Transport vor und zurück dann natürlich
das ist eine sehr schwierige
Angelegenheit weil die Engstellen über
den napper das geht ja im Moment auch
nur durch Ponton Brücken werden von den
Ukrainern weiter beschossen und die
russische Seite hat deswegen auch ein
Teil zumindest der Zivilbevölkerung und
der Zivilverwaltung vor allem der
kollaborationsverwaltung zurückgezogen
das ist schon eine erhebliche Gefahr
auch für die Russen wenn sie sich dort
in der Stadt festkrallen wird das für
die Ukraine natürlich auch sehr
schwierig es kommt aber vor allem darauf
an dass Umfeld das Umland Umkehr Sonnen
aus russischer Sicht zu halten oder aus
ukrainischer Sicht zu nehmen denn wenn
Personen eingeschlossen wird und es den
Russen nicht gelingt das Gelände
zwischen Kasern und dem depper auch
wirklich im Griff unterhalten dann droht
ihnen das gleiche Schicksal wie das den
Ukrainern im Mai in mariopold gegangen
ist das heißt wir werden eingeschlossen
können sich nicht mehr versorgen müssen
irgendwann aufgeben das werden die
Russen versuchen zu verhindern wir sehen
hier Bilder jetzt von vom 6.11 muss man
dazu sagen also Ganztages aktuell haben
wir sie jetzt nicht ist ja auch immer
schwierig hinzukommen und von dort zu
berichten ist klar aber natürlich sehen
wir sozusagen wie sich beide Seiten dort
vorbereiten auf das was in den nächsten
Tagen ansteht Putin hat heute noch mal
gesagt was die Truppenstärke seiner
seiner Soldaten anbetrifft dass derzeit
50.000 russische Soldaten in der Ukraine
sein weitere 80.000 in der sogenannten
Zone der speziellen Militäroperation man
darf hier in Russland nicht vom Krieg
reden und der Rest der 320.000
eingezogenen sind demnach in
Ausbildungslagern derzeit das sind
enormen Summen das sind enorme
Größenordnungen will Putin damit einmal
mehr auch klar machen heute an so nenn
ich mal menschennachsch jetzt nicht
ja absolut also diese Tatsache dass man
300.000 Soldaten mobilisieren konnte
zeigt wie viele Ressourcen zumindest
personell die Russen haben etwas
schwieriger wird es bei der
Materialversorgung auch dort haben sie
natürlich sehr viele Ressourcen das
heißt eine großen eine große Anzahl von
Kampfpanzer und Artilleriegeschützen
oder gepanzerten in Depots aber die sind
natürlich alle nicht alle in einem guten
Zustand man muss den instand setzen das
soll eine Weile dauern und das mag auch
erklären warum derzeit etwa 50.000
tatsächlich im Einsatz sind in den
Kriegsgebieten und die werden offenbar
dazu benutzt um die Verbände die ja
große Verluste erlitten haben vor Ort zu
verstärken zumindest ist es den Russen
gelungen die Front hier zu stabilisieren
auch wenn man am Kampf fährt dieser
relativ schnell nach vorne gebrachten
Reservisten zweifeln mag ja wir sehen
hier auch noch mal den Frontverlauf
momentan und dazu gibt es auch eine
Frage wie er Youtube Rom fragt können
die Berliner die Russen in herson von
Norden her nicht einkesseln und dann im
Winter aushungern lassen ein Häuserkampf
kostet viel Blut was man so leicht
vermeiden könnte
ja das ist genau das was ich vorhin
angesprochen habe ein Häuserkampf ist
sehr blutig und das werden beide Seiten
versuchen möglichst also zumindest die
Ukrainer müssen es versuchen zu
vermeiden denn auch sie hatten natürlich
große Verluste während der Russen
mittlerweile ihre Verluste personell
wieder aufgefüllt oder kompensiert haben
aber das Umland um kerson herum ist in
der Tat das entscheidende der
entscheidende Faktor wenn es den
Ukrainern gelingen sollte Carson
einzuschließen brauchen Sie den
Häuserkampf nicht unbedingt müssen Sie
sich nicht darauf einlassen sondern
können warten bis diese Kräfte keine
Versorgung mehr haben und dann aufgeben
müssen wie das in mariopol der Fall war
und umgekehrt werden die Russen das zu
verhindern suchen und dafür haben sie ja
auch sehr viel Personal nach vorne
geschoben und wir müssen davon ausgehen
dass es sich hier um einen
abnutzungskrieg handelt der in den
Winter hineingeht das britische
Verteidigungsministerium hat heute
getwittert und wir haben das hier
vorliegen ich kann hier mal ein bisschen
das zeigen wie es steht momentan wurde
diese Pressemitteilung so veröffentlicht
und dem ihr könnt das hier lesen ist
klar dass momentan so sagt London
Russland demnach 278 Flugzeuge verloren
hat im Vergleich dazu im Afghanistan
Krieg waren es 119 und
Briten die Großbritannien also die
Briten davon ausgehen dass Russland
damit momentan die Lufthoheit verloren
hat dort in der Region wie verheerend
ist das für die Kriegsführung aus Moskau
Sicht also auch das muss man einordnen
also wenn man von vom Kriegsbeginn
anrechnet dann hatten die Ukraine etwa
125 kampflokzeuge die aktiv in der Lage
waren Gefechte dort auszuführen und die
Russen hat ein guter zehnfache sie
verfügen insgesamt allerdings verteilt
auf das natürlich sehr große Territorium
Russlands über mehr als 1300
kampflokzeuge wenn Sie diese verlustzahl
die ich natürlich nicht verifizieren
kann aber ich nehme sie mal ins
Verhältnis setzen dann hätten die Russen
tatsächlich 20 Prozent ihre Luftwaffe
verloren der Begriff Lufthoheit und Luft
Überlegenheit den müssen wir noch mal
erklären die
[Musik]
luft-verteidigung wirklich nieder zu
kämpfen und auszuschalten die
Luftverteilung wirkt immer noch und zwar
immer besser einig und die
Kampfflugzeuge der Ukrainer starten auch
immer noch also auch hier können wir
sehen dass es maximal um den Begriff
Luft Überlegenheit ging niemals um
Luftherrschaft und dass die also dass
die Russen die Lufthoheit verloren haben
das kann man deswegen auch nicht sagen
aber die Luft Überlegenheit glaube ich
haben sie immer noch denn sie haben noch
Material Reserven schauen wir noch auf
einen anderen wichtigen Punkt bevor wir
gleich unseren Reporter dazu holen auf
den carovka Staudamm auch da gibt es
heute und in den vergangenen Tagen
gegenseitige Vorwürfe angeblich sei er
vermiet um mir einen weiteren Vorrücken
der Ukraine zu sprengen beide Seiten
werfen sich vor dies möglicherweise zu
tun wir sehen den auch hier noch mal auf
der Karte wo er ist warum ist dieser
Staudamm so wichtig welche Rolle spielte
in diesem Krieg
ja zunächst zunächst einmal ist er
wichtig also für die Stromversorgung es
handelt sich hier um einen Kraftwerk das
mit Wasser betrieben wird also mit
gestautem Wasser dann funktioniert
sicherlich auch Wasserversorgung aber
ich glaube das spielt hier nicht die
große Rolle es ist für beide Seiten von
Bedeutung diese Elektrizität natürlich
zu nutzen für die ukrainische Seite das
liegt auf der Hand weil die ganze
kritische Infrastruktur natürlich sehr
stark von der vom Strom abhängt
insbesondere auch die Eisenbahn die ja
im Wesentlichen elektrisch fährt und
natürlich auch für die russische Salbe
die versuchen muss diese Quelle zu
nutzen um die Creme beispielsweise zu
versorgen
wenn man ich gehe auch davon aus dass
die russische Seite vorsorglich
sozusagen den
Nova Karow da vermiet hat dazu braucht
man aber schon sehr sehr große Ladung
und da braucht man Spezialkräfte man
muss tief in den Beton einbauen das sind
ja riesen massive betonw dort und ich
gehe nicht davon aus dass die eine oder
andere Seite es wirklich vor hat zu
sprengen sondern das ist eher eine
notenmaßnahme ja aus russischer Sicht
für den Fall dass die Ukraine
tatsächlich vorrücken sollten würde man
das tun und würde es gelingen eine
größere Bresche in diesen Staudamm
wirklich zu schlagen dann allerdings
wäre das Strom abwärts gelegene Land
sehr schnell überflutet das würde
bedeuten die Russen könnten ihre eigenen
Truppen nicht mehr versorgen die
inkassonnen legen umgekehrt wäre es für
die Ukraine ein riesenhindernis dann
auch weiter nach Osten vorzustoßen und
sicherlich hat nie hat haben die Ukraine
kein Interesse daran ihre eigene
Bevölkerung damit zu schaden auch ein
weiteres enormes druckpotenzial von
beiden Seiten auf jeden Fall wir
sprechen gleich weiter wollen dann noch
mal auf die Rolle Europas auch Amerikas
schauen was Nachschub etc betrifft auch
moralische Unterstützung wir sprechen
wie gesagt gleich weiter wollen aber
jetzt mal unseren Reporter dazu holen da
Hassan der einmal mehr für uns fürs ZDF
dort in der Ukraine unterwegs ist guten
Abend daran du bist den saporisch ja und
hast heute eine durchaus spannende Reise
mal wieder gemacht für uns wo warst du
heute und was hast du dort gesehen und
erlebt
ja wir sind heute nach nicopol gefahren
und das ist die Stadt die genau
gegenüber dem größten Atomkraftwerk
Europas liegt dem Atomkraftwerk sapo
Richard mit seinen sechs Reaktoren und
diese Stadt ist permanent unter Beschuss
von der anderen Seite die
russische Armee ist auf der anderen
Seite des Flusses stationiert und es
gibt eben dieser Stadt im Grunde zwei
Fronten die eine ist auf der anderen
Seite des Flussufers wo sie nicht
hinkommen und zurückschießen ist
natürlich auch äußerst riskant und das
hat uns heute auch der
militärkommandeur bestätigt sie haben es
von der oberen
vorm Oberkommando auch verboten bekommen
die Hoffnung ist dass alle das gesamte
Gebiet um das AKW
die militarisiert wird und diese
Verhandlungen auf die setzt die Ukraine
in dem Bereich auf dem rechten flussuf
konnte die ukrainische Armee aber
wirklich deutlich vordringen und hat in
den letzten Wochen große Gebietsgewinne
erzielt mit derselben Taktik die wir
zuvorher auch um nikolaje beobachten
konnten
Dorfe Dorf wird eingenommen immer dann
wenn man es auch halten kann und dann
wird weiter vorgerückt sehr langsam wir
haben Nikolai F mit Soldaten gesprochen
direkt an der Front die im Einsatz sind
ein Artillerie Brigade war das und unter
den Soldaten ist nach all diesen Wochen
schon eine Ungeduld zu spüren sie sind
überzeugt dass sie auch im Häuserkampf
überlegen sind dass Ihre Motivation die
Ortskenntnis
sie absolut auf die Siegerstraße bringen
würden der Captain der Brigade hat
allerdings gesagt dass die das
Oberkommando genau das Gegenteil will
sie wollen weiter sehr besonnen sehr
langsam vorrücken und das müssen die
Soldaten die müssen ihre Ungeduld jetzt
noch ein bisschen im Zaum halten aber
natürlich steckt ja auch dahin
genau wie du sagst also das ist ja schon
die die Strategie sozusagen die wir auch
vorhin ja gehört haben Menschenleben
dort zu schützen und eben nicht blind in
diesen in diesen Kampf um diese Stadt
hineinzurennen dazu noch mal wir haben
es ja gesehen und du hast es uns in
mehreren Reportagen schon immer wieder
gezeigt was gerade passiert mit dem
gezielten zerstören der Infrastruktur
was ja eben auch die Folgen für die für
den Nachschub mit sich zieht ist das
eine aber eben auch natürlich für die
Bevölkerung wir sehen Bilder gleich Kiew
ist immer wieder dunkel dort wird Strom
gespart wird ausgestellt damit das Netz
nicht zusammenbricht erbricht völlig
kollabiert und auch Klitschko der
Bürgermeister von Kiew hat in einem
Interview noch mal gesagt die Menschen
müssen sich auf das Schlimmste
vorbereiten man muss Strom sparen und es
gilt die Warnung vor einem Blackout wie
ernst wird das genommen wie sehr nehmen
die Menschen das an
oh das nehmen sie sehr an sie spüren es
ja auch schon seit längerem es ist so
dass das Stromnetz wirklich am Rande ist
in die Knie zu gehen die Menschen haben
Vorbereitungen getroffen sie haben sich
dran gewöhnt dass es einen klaren Plan
gibt für die größeren Städte wann
Elektrizität da ist wann gezielt
abgestaltet abgeschaltet wird es gibt
aber auch Orte wie zum Beispiel Nikopol
wo wir heute waren wo der Strom so
unzuverlässig vorhanden ist das die
Menschen sich da gar nicht drauf
verlassen können es gibt
findige Tüftler die sich über
Autobatterien eine
sichern dass ihre ihre Internet-Router
laufen über mehrere Stunden und immer
wenn Strom da ist nutzen sie natürlich
das um alle Batterien um um elektrische
Akkus aufzuladen für Licht für Essen für
um essen zu können auch sind
Bunsenbrenner fast ausverkauft ich war
mit meinem Team in den outdoor-läden die
sind sich dafür da dass die Menschen in
der Wildnis autark leben können und
jetzt hat uns die Verkäuferin gesagt ist
es genau umgekehrt sie brauchen es für
das städtische Leben hier um ja um hier
noch weiter leben zu können und kochen
zu können um Licht zu haben um ja
durchzukommen wir sehen es ja auch du
trägst auch eine dicke Jacke welche
Temperaturen herrschen derzeit
es ist eigentlich noch okay heute hat
die ganze den ganzen Tag die Sonne
geschienen aber es waren doch drei vier
Grad und das wird nachts natürlich dann
immer noch ein bisschen kälter die kalte
Hand des Winters greift schon uns so ein
bisschen in den Nacken und es wird
kälter werden das ist ganz klar und die
Ukraine kennen ihre Winter du hast es
gesagt sie Menschen die eigentlich in
der Stadt leben gewohnt sind Licht an zu
machen Heizung aufzudrehen richten sich
also jetzt darauf ein mit Gerätschaften
die eigentlich für Outdoor gedacht sind
sozusagen innerhalb der Stadt durch
diese Zeit jetzt zu kommen wenn du mit
ihnen sprichst wenn du auch mit den
Soldaten sprichst du hast vorhin schon
gesagt sie sind sehr motiviert
eigentlich jetzt weiter zu kämpfen und
und weiter voranzuschreiten und du
machst es ja schon seit Wochen und
Monaten fürs ZDF erlebst du deine
Veränderung wird noch mal anders geguckt
sind die Erfolgsmeldungen der letzten
Tage und Wochen einerseits noch mal ein
Schub für die Motivation oder merkt man
doch jetzt wie lange dieser Krieg schon
dauert und wie schwer er sein wird jetzt
durch den Winter zu bringen
ja man sieht da die gesamte Bandbreite
und ich bin auch jetzt vorsichtig zu
sagen dass alle
Ukraine
ungebrochenen Willen und voller
Optimismus sind es man erlebt alles die
Menschen die hier geblieben sind
versuchen das Beste zu machen und
durchzuhalten und
von daher so die die alle aufgeben kann
man das spürt man nirgends aber heute
zum Beispiel in Nico Paul diese Stadt
sie hatte schon was deprimierendes die
Menschen die dort waren das sind noch
ungefähr 30 Prozent der ursprünglichen
Bevölkerung sie sind die Menschen die
nicht weg können sei es weil sie nicht
wissen wie wohin und wie man reist weil
sie immer in einem Ort gelebt haben oder
weil ihnen die finanziellen Mittel
fehlen es gab sehr sehr viele alte
Menschen die alleine über die Straßen
gingen und diese Menschen
die die müssen durchhalten also da
kann man jetzt nicht so viel von
Optimismus sprechen aber sie gehen dann
auch hin und sammeln Laub ein während
man Artillerie
gedonner im Hintergrund rund hält also
das ist schon eine Art von durchhalten
wo man wirklich auf der anderen Seite
auch wieder beeindruckt ist unser Leben
danke einmal mehr für deine
Schilderungen live aus der Ukraine außer
purricia gute Nacht und bis bald danke
fürs berichten einmal mehr danke und
damit zurück noch mal zu oberst ad
Wolfgang Richter von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik wir haben es
vorhineingangs gehört was daran
geschildert hat die Militärführung
sozusagen bremst ein bisschen und sagt
und sie meinten es vorhin ja auch jetzt
nicht in diesen Häuserkampf ziehen nicht
den blutigen Krieg suchen sondern eben
man habe Zeit das hat Putin auch einmal
gesagt auf was müssen wir uns über das
aus der Ferne beobachten einstellen
nimmt man sich Zeit diesen Krieg noch
lange und schmutzig zu führen
ja also ich glaube dass beide Seiten
sich auf einen langen abnutzungskrieg im
Moment einstellen das ist so der Russen
werden nicht aufgeben im Moment auf wenn
Sie eine Schwächephase erlitten haben
und auch Niederlagen und auch hohe
Verluste erlitten haben aber sie haben
gezeigt dass sie ihre Verluste auch
kompensieren kann mit der teilmobil
machen zum Beispiel und die Ukraine
natürlich wissen wofür sie kämpfen sie
kämpfen für eure Unabhängigkeit und
Souveränität und sie werden durchhalten
trotzdem sehe ich eine Asymmetrie hier
der die Russen können noch auf sehr
viele eigene Kräfte zurückgreifen sowohl
materiell aus aus als auch personell
werden die Ukraine je mehr Waffensysteme
sie aus dem besten einführen je mehr
werden Sie auch von der Logistik des
Westens abhängig sein denn sie können ja
nicht westliche Munition produzieren und
der westliche Ersatzteile für dieses
Systeme zumal die Produktivität der
ukrainischen Rüstungsindustrie ohnehin
kriegsbedingt zurückgegangen ist das
heißt die Frage der Durchhaltefähigkeit
richtet sich hier mindestens ebenso an
den Westen wie an die Ukraine ganz
wesentlicher Punkt und surfex fragt auch
genau danach wie er Youtube wie steht es
denn nun eigentlich mit
Materialnachschub von unserer und von
europäischer Seite sie haben es ja
gerade schon gesagt während Russland
sozusagen aus dem Arsenal sich bedienen
kann dem eigenen ist die Ukraine auf
Lieferungen angewiesen wie schätzen Sie
das ein und auch noch mal auf diese
Frage einkommt nicht nur was geliefert
wird sondern wie groß auch der Wille ist
weiterhin zu liefern
also ich glaube in Europa wird es am
politischen Willen nicht mangeln trotz
der fehlenden Diskussion die wir gerade
in Deutschland haben
es geht eher um eine Balance einerseits
als nicht Kriegspartei nicht
hineingezogen zu werden nicht weiter zu
eskalieren auf der anderen Seite aber
doch die Ukraine ganz eindeutig zu
unterstützen ich glaube man darf auch
nicht nur auf die einzelnen
Waffensysteme gucken da war ja viel
Diskussion über bestimmte Waffensysteme
im Moment angesichts der Luftangriffe
der Russen kommt es auf Luftverteidigung
vor allen Dingen an und auch die
weitreichende Artillerie die präziser
schießende Artillerie hat sich ja nun
sehr bewährt ich glaube an der Stelle
wird man auch weitermachen und
Deutschland hat ja auch ganz ansehnlich
geliefert und das muss man dann aber in
den Kontext stellen denn der Lieferung
insgesamt mein Problem ist er dass die
Logistik in einem Krieg natürlich
Kriegsproduktion erfordert das heißt man
muss Munition in sehr sehr großen Mengen
produzieren darauf ist die westliche
gerade in Europa die Industrie überhaupt
nicht eingestellt und zumal das ganze
auch noch in einem gewissen Wettbewerb
liegt mit den eigenen Erfordernissen die
Verteidigung der NATO sicher zu stellen
und zum Beispiel in Deutschland jetzt
die Bundeswehr auf einen Status zu
bringen der dann auch wirklich als
vollverteidigungsfähig gilt und wenn ich
nur denke dass Munition für 20
Milliarden Euro angeschafft werden muss
damit man zumindest ein 30-tages-vorrat
hat der ein hochintensiven Krieg
entspricht dann kann man sich ungefähr
vorstellen was hier passiert und die
Industrie wäre auch nicht innerhalb
weniger Tage in der Lage diese 20
Milliarden wirklich umzusetzen in
Produktion also ich sehe hier schon auch
ökonomische Risiken
Amerika gleich sofort aber weil das sehr
wichtig und sehr komplex ist damit man
da wirklich auch gut nachkommt geben sie
uns meine Größenordnung wie viel
Munition sozusagen wird gebraucht sie
haben das Beispiel vorhin genannt aber
wie viel Munition wird gebraucht und wie
viel ist im Verhältnis dazu überhaupt in
europäischen amerikanischen lagern die
man überhaupt auch rüber kann und auch
was nachschubsschwierigkeiten bedeutet
schaffen kann sie dorthin zu bringen das
heißt wie viel braucht man dafür damit
das was sie gerade geschildert haben
überhaupt tatsächlich stattfinden kann
und wie sehr sind unsere europäischen
Produktionsmittel überhaupt derzeit
dafür ausgelegt
ja also um eine Zahl sondern wenn ich an
die Artillerie denke die ukrainische
Artillerie verstehst pro Tag 5 bis 6000
Granaten und das sind wirklich ziemlich
schwere Kaliber das sind 122 oder 152 mm
Kaliber das heißt die Granaten liegen
zwischen 20 und 40 Kilo manche auch
schwerer und wenn man das hochrechnet
dann weiß man wie viele Güter Waggons
man da liefern muss und das täglich und
auf eine solche Massenproduktion ist man
natürlich nicht eingestellt selbst wenn
ich jetzt alle Staaten zusammennehme
also es gibt natürlich in den östlichen
Staaten der NATO noch einige
Produktionsstätten die noch sowjetische
Kaliber also Munition sowjetischen
Kalibers produzieren das ist aber nicht
mehr so viele und je mehr westliche
Systeme geliefert werden je mehr müsste
man also auch von dieser Munition
liefern ich sehe hier ökonomische
Begrenzung natürlich ist es richtig wenn
alle zusammen jetzt etwas liefern dann
entsteht da schon auch etwas aber ob man
das jetzt langfristig durchhalten kann
ohne massiv auf die Industrie
einzuwirken das sage ich zu bezweifeln
das müsste eigentlich geschehen damit
hier eine Art von Kriegsproduktion
zustande kommt ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob das so kurzfristig gelingen kann
im Land selbst und das ist auch nur eine
Frage die Manfred wie känzer wir
facebook stellt wie denn diese
Waffenlieferungen dort hinkommen wo sie
gebraucht werden wenn Russland doch die
Infrastruktur derzeit so gezielt
zerstört kommt das noch mal erschwerend
hinzu das kommt erschwerend hinzu selbst
wenn also diese
munitionsmengen geliefert werden sollten
dann muss man sich aber erstmal an die
Front bringen und wenn man jetzt das tut
was die Russen ja auch gegenwärtig tun
nämlich die kritische Infrastruktur
anzugreifen insbesondere die
Stromversorgung dann wird das mit der
Bahn sehr schwierig werden ich meine
noch gibt es Elektrizität sie muss dann
eben teilweise eingeschränkt werden wir
wissen haben bisher 40 Prozent etwa
zerstört der
Elektrizitätsversorgung der Westen hilft
aber auch bei der Reparatur die Ukrainer
tun ihr Bestes es ist also ein Wettlauf
zwischen Reparatur und zwischen weiterer
Zerstörung und an beide Seiten richtet
sich die Frage wie lange hält man das
durch die Russen haben auch nicht endlos
Zahlen an kaliberraketen oder oder es
kann da sie greifen jetzt mehr auf
iranisch gemachte leichte Drohnen zurück
die einfach billiger sind und daraus
kann man erkennen dass auch für die
Russen nicht alles endlos möglich ist
also es ist ein Wettlauf ich wollte noch
einmal auf die politischen
auch sozusagen mit Blick auf die Uhr
Richtung Ende dann schon gehen aber in
der Tat wir erleben jetzt mit Herrn
Wahlen und Äußerungen die da auch im
Vorfeld gemacht werden wie wichtig ist
das in diesem ganzen Kontext ja das ist
absolut wichtig wir wissen also noch
nicht wie die mit terms ausgehen werden
das wird da werden wir morgen übermorgen
etwas schlauer sein es gibt aber
skeptische Stimmen gerade auch bei den
Republikanern die sagen wie lange wollen
wir das noch durchhalten wir müssen das
Zurückfahren wir müssen an unsere
eigenen Streitkräfte denken gerade bei
der weitreichenden heimatmunition hat
man also doch schon sehr viel verbraucht
und es spannende Stimmen die sagen wir
können nicht unsere eigenen Arsenale
angreifen aber die politischen Risiken
insgesamt werden sicherlich wachsen vor
allen Dingen wenn es auf den nächsten
Präsidentschaftswahlen zugeht wo es ja
noch unsicherer ist wäre dann der
nächste Präsident wird sollte es ein Art
eine Art Trump Nachfolger werden dann
würden sich die politischen Gewichte
verschieben und das sind alles gute
Gründe weshalb es glaube ich ganz
vernünftig ist diesen Krieg sobald es
möglich ist zu einem Ende zu bringen
allerdings zu einem Ende ohne
Zugeständnisse die zulassen der Ukraine
geht und zu einem vernünftigen Ende dass
die Souveränität und Unabhängigkeit der
Ukraine war und nicht mit
Maximalforderungen von vornherein
unmöglich gemacht wird absolut
abschließende Frage wir haben in der
vergangenen Woche ein erstaunliches
Machtwort aus China gehört wenn wir von
Amerika reden wenn wir von Europa reden
müssen wir auch in dem Kontext über
China reden
bisher war China nicht aufgefallen dass
man sich da eingemischt hat in großen
Stile weil man auch nicht möchte dass
man sich in chinesische Angelegenheiten
einmischt Stichwort Taiwan etc und
trotzdem war es ja überraschend zu hören
als der Bundeskanzler in Peking war dass
dann doch ein merkliches Grummeln und
eine klare Äußerung von Chinas
Machthabern kam wie wichtig ist das und
wie sehr beeindruckt das Putin also das
ist absolut wichtig Kinder spielt hier
eine Schlüsselrolle
China kann auf der einen Seite Russland
nicht fallen lassen weil China weiß dass
es in einem strategischen in einer
strategischen Rivalität mit den USA sich
befindet würde man Russland fallen
lassen wo würde China am Ende alleine
stehen das ist jedenfalls die
Kalkulation in Peking auf der anderen
Seite ist man aber auch interessiert
diese regelbasierte Ordnung so wie es
Peking versteht durchaus zu bewahren
also die wesentlichen Prinzipien der
un-kater einfach deswegen weil man
selbst Interesse daran hat dass man sich
nicht in die internen Angelegenheiten
zum Beispiel was einmischt natürlich in
Klammern immer unter der Maske dass man
Taiwaner asthal China sieht als im
Rahmen der ein Kinderpolitik aber diese
nicht Einmischung und die territuale
Integrität zu waren ist eben etwas
Wichtiges und deswegen kann China diesen
Krieg nicht gutheißen den Russland hier
führt und schon gar nicht gut heißen
kann China einen antasten der nuklearen
Ordnung die es zumindest durch selber
Rasseln gegeben hat ich glaube da würde
China sehr sensitiv reagieren und das
hat auch einen klaren Regel vorgeschoben
über bei allen Diskussionen die wir
hatten über den Einsatz taktischer
Nuklearwaffen das ist das Letzte was
Kinder will dass diese nukleare Ordnung
weltweit zusammenbricht sprich die
Nichtverbreitung das nvv-system und dann
irgendwelche Staaten die glauben sie
müssen sich notfalls nuklear verteidigen
gegen an aggressive Nuklearwaffen
starten das würde tatsächlich die Welt
destabilisieren daran hat China kein
Interesse Wolfgang Richter vielen Dank
viele Interessen
viele wichtige Informationen viele
einzelne kleine Informationen die
zusammen das eine große Bild der geben
an einem Tag ich sag das eingangs den
ich dadurch besticht dass es die eine
große Schlagzeile gibt aber wie wichtig
es ist immer wieder hinzuschauen immer
wieder auf dieses Leid zu schauen und
darauf zu schauen wie dieses Land sich
auf diesen Krieg weiterhin auch jetzt
Richtung Winter vorbereitet und womit es
zu kämpfen hat dafür war diese Sendung
heute danke für euer Interesse danke für
eure Fragen und Kommentare und bis zum
nächsten Mal macht's gut tschüss